[Music]
tactical shooters have been a
force in online gaming for almost
two decades they rely on carefully
crafted and refined
strategies to gain the tiniest of
advantages over your opponents
so oftentimes the biggest brains on the
battlefield
come out on top but now is the hard part
now he's gonna deal with the player
upstairs and this is not going to be an
easy factor at all he does not have the
nitrous still to confirm the easy kill
oh oh what is this there's no way that
leon's gonna be able to read into this
maybe he has no
he's noticed that the nade goes in it's
gonna impact it should connect but no
not in time just a moment too late an
empire
3 billion iq from a little tricky you
smoke up like this
pass it up like this twice you go with
the flashes
rush through the smoke go around like
this and if you're lucky there's gonna
be a guy right here standing
trust and teamwork are hallmarks of the
genre but of course there are mavericks
who
take matters into their own hands oh
never mind he's actually gonna push him
a molly and lord peak yes ghoster
he started his adventures at inner and
now he's fighting man he goes for an
and another one go on these games have
developed a core
set of values over the years with each
player filling a specific role for their
team
smokes flashes and other forms of
utility are used to create
space and cut off choke points and
everyone needs to be on the same page
to succeed
and being the genre's new kid on the
block valorant has chosen to adopt
many of these same values
but the thing about rules and tradition
is that not everyone's interested in
following
that's a perfect tag it's forced for del
out he can't counsel the old
and the curveball last straight in
wardell's face there goes asana
he is devastating he takes down two
players with the run it back
what a beautiful conversion off of his
ultimate assange defending
very close oh asana
meet peter asuna mazurik 100 thieves is
a zealful zoomer whose aggressive
playstyle and absurdly cracked aim
has not only helped the thieves become
one of the best valorem teams in north
america
but earned asuna a reputation as one of
the game's
flashiest fraggers
is the triple off the rocket is the
fourth kill he's working on the ac
absolutely monstrous performance so how
is it that asuna is able to
decimate his opponents whilst playing in
such an absurdly
structured team and what is it about
valorent in particular that enables him
to play
in such an exciting bloodthirsty way
who were able to pick up the pieces how
is there coming over this is also going
to try to make his way in
finds the first kill wait things will
calm down for just a moment
wait now a 1v1
[Music]
okay so in addition to winning the first
big valorant event and being the lone
teenager on a roster
filled with wrinkly ass cs players who
is this kid with an anime alias well
when he's not
weebing out on twitter or adding people
to his highlight reel on the server
you can find this supremely talented 17
year old
spending his free time completing high
school
i mean i only have like four to five
hours of free time generally speaking
and then like some of the times for
homework and stuff
so it's like kind of hard to find time
to do other stuff but i mean
you have to sacrifice some things to do
stuff you love so it works out
and as with most valorant fiends asuna
got his start
playing counter-strike he began playing
professionally back in may of 2019
and jumped around various up-and-coming
rosters before joining triumph alongside
nacs's lord and savior michael
grimm wince and he's good enough to
bring the crack back still asuna with
that hog
gets one gets two but with a lack of
opportunities in his region's tier two
counter-strike scene
asuna saw a chance to make a name for
himself with the release of riot's new
tactical shooter
and given the relationships he'd built
in cs go it wasn't long before sooner
found himself on the immortals roster in
june of 2020.
they found me by uh the word of mouth
the four that they already had on the
team hyped me up a lot they said i was
insane and ranked and like i was very
good in cs
so then i tried out as breach i played
really badly they didn't message me back
for like a week and then
eventually they decided to try me out on
raise and i played insane and they
picked me up something you guys should
know about me
oh that's
oh doesn't get a kill though but it does
a ton of damage there to the stage
the sage has to bail the name's going to
be sent down i think the stage is
playing inside
of the site there so the coverage is
going to be so vital in that instance
but asana pushes forward what a shot
there
sending out gary does gary give him what
he needs maybe it's going to be the
grenade that actually locks down that
kill enough to not get
it on the walls out the walls out it
just leaves venerated by himself
and they actually have he go on the
other side and they get the kills
immortals i cannot believe it immortals
they're moving on to the next round in
the span of just two months asuna had
established himself as one of the most
impressive entry fraggers in the whole
of valrant
and while fans fawned over his
highlights it was his potential
star power that caught the attention of
a hundred thieves
you see for whatever reason when they
first decided to enter valorant hundred
thieves thought it would be a great idea
to give old man hiko
four former pubg players to work with
and
after it quickly became apparent that
that wasn't a likely path to success
the thieves hit reset on the project
choosing to only
retain heiko's services and not long
after that
asuna became part of their plans so they
messaged me on twitter
i um just responded back to hiko saying
yeah i'm free to try out i tried out we
like uh remember the first scrim or
second script we played was against tsm
it was two maps we took a map off them
actually i was almost positive we would
join after that scrim because like csm
at that time was like really good
yeah after that they just picked us up
and then we had a two
two week trial period actually just to
like make sure that we were the right
fit and then
we signed after that once the new and
improved hundred thieves had been
assembled
asuna found himself alongside a core of
experienced boomers who'd made their
name
in counter-strike and it was with this
roster that asuna was able to
fully express the hyper aggressive
playstyle for which he'd become known
soon already around the back oh my
goodness hundred thoughts never stood a
chance it's the 3k
for azuna who gets a quads and sooner
the newest recruits 200 thieves
looking good so far and that's the
ultimate the show stopper connects coach
wow this time in their admin
so so well done there some cracks into
the site now there goes the rocket
beautiful from a hundred feet
down death from above
oh that's annoying off the rocket it's a
fourth kill
absolutely monstrous performance there
on short a look
as colors tries he does all that he can
but it's simply not enough against a
hundred
thieves a hundred thieves they've done
it they are your first strike
north america champions now part of the
thing that made asuna such a
linchpin to the thieves success was his
ability to
catch his opponents off guard with his
full throttle play style and if you've
ever played a tactical shooter
you'll know for a fact that holding w
isn't exactly a reliable path to success
for instance in a game like
counter-strike economy matters
pistol rounds are crucial in order to
dictate the flow of the game on both
sides of the half
and utility must be spread out across
the map allowing each player to succeed
in their given role
what's more weapons have different spray
patterns rate of fire and
effective range and all of these things
must be considered in order to get the
best bang for your buck
but one of the biggest differences
between cs and valorant
is that valorant was designed in such a
way that allows lunatics like asuna
to run and gun their way around the map
with more than decent accuracy
instead of relying on utility or rifles
to gain an advantage
asuna has shown that he's fully capable
of just
blast packing his way onto sight and
destroying everyone with just about any
weapon
the race is available they have to go
tackle that one right now they're pretty
high committed
on the thief again three kills
i hate this character
you know that guy jumped off the box and
then he got me
yeah i feel like in cs go you're kind of
everyone has the same kit so you can't
be this like hyper aggressive player in
cs go
you have to like know the in-betweens
like you can't be like
you have to sometimes be more passive
sometimes really aggressive you can't
just like
be in one mode but in this game i feel
like you can be in that one mode of
super aggressive we play like these
agents that allow this to
happen like rey's double satcheling in
you have the phoenix flashes and
other players don't have these kids like
cypher and killjoy players can't be this
super aggressive player
so the agents give these players their
own play style and they promote
identity in each individual i feel like
and that is the big difference between
like csgo and valorent and although
people love
watching asuna absolutely clown on kids
and twitch highlights
ride has faced severe backlash from the
valorem community for allowing this
irreverent style of play
to dominate the meta for so long in fact
running and gunning became so relied
upon that it was actually thought to be
harming the competitive scene the
stinger and frenzy for instance were so
busted that oftentimes teams were
winning eco rounds with ease
using these cheap ass criminally
overpowered weapons
hell i still think that the frenzy is
the best rifle in valorant
but finally nearly a year after
valoran's release
riot has slowly started to nerf them
but in spite of these significant
changes
asuna isn't all that worried right now
they're tackling it slowly right now
they just upped the frenzy price
so i'll see what direction like ryan
goes and how much they nerf it uh
the stinger they plan on uh i'm pretty
sure they just like up the
recoil the lower the rate of fire so i
mean i'll have to try it out but
i'll probably have to just like you know
get better with other guns as simple as
that
because the more that riot continues to
tinker with valorent's balancing formula
the more the game continues to grow
and evolve now while it might seem as
though asuna is just some mindless
prodigious aimbot
like just about every other fps player
we make videos about
the truth is that this kid isn't just
running on sight and senselessly going
burr in fact part of the reason why
asuna has become so
successful with this w key breaking
playstyle
is that the experience and structure his
teammates form around him
enables him to play that way it almost
feels like if i make a bad play and i'm
i'm like i got first blooded at the
start around but like they have the
rounds still
i i'm almost positive no other player
can feel like this but like even if i
make a really bad play and i die first i
feel like they can still clutch it out
no matter the scenario even at 3v5
definitely feels like there's a lot less
pressure when i take these fights
knowing that i have
them three i'm hoping at least that they
can provide it right here they're
looking to push
immediately towards a main it doesn't
seem to be going their way again
tanner the action it begins so quickly
and it might end
even quicker three kills immediately for
asana
and while 100 thieves have had some
shaky performances as of late
asuna is just happy that competition and
valorant is growing stronger
if anything he believes that these
changes will allow valorent to be played
in a more strategic way which can only
bolster the health of the game's
competitive scene it feels like
every month the skill ceiling gets
raised and like it gets harder and it
feels like
you have to look out for more things in
the game and like
how the meta is changing like right now
i think cs has a higher skill ceiling
that's only because like the game's been
out for 10 years and people were able to
like
maximize it and like i feel like valerie
there's a lot more to maximize
in my eyes maybe not mechanically but if
you're getting full blinded
there's no way to like shoot back at a
person regardless of how good your
mechanics are
so i feel like a lot of innovation with
abilities which make the game
have a higher skill ceiling in a
different way than in cs
so i think it makes the game a lot more
creative and a lot more
i guess like an art form in a way and
even if riot tries to nerf this hyper
aggressive play style into the ground
asuna knows that he can always just
overcome the challenge
because this kid is just that good at
popping heads
even these little flashbacks like
this man's feeling himself i own hookah
you do not belong holy [ __ ] i love it
sits in the game i'll abuse it if it's
not it's like whatever i'll find a way
to just like you know
overcome it so that's just my take prime
for 12 unless someone can absolutely pop
off is it time for asuna well maybe
finds himself too that will allow hiko
to get onto the site
has to clear out showers does he get a
timing here onto android
juan's trying to push he's the weapon
finally the kill awesome enough for
three
2v2 situation now it falls on the
shoulders of azuna
would have to be an ace it's information
finds the fourth
knows where the last player is paige
trying to push him out but
can he actually find the kill in time
blast back over
thank you will use this to get at least
halfway in the defusal
shanks on the opposite picture in
picture oh my
god
i'll tell you this the frenzy is a
shitload better than the cz in
counter-strike it is
it's super good it has like the most
controllable spray pattern it has a
better spray pattern than the rifles
and the point of the cz in
counter-strike is essentially it's a gun
stealer's weapon
i'm gonna camp in this corner wait till
somebody with a rifle
crosses me and then i'm gonna shoot them
from point blank and i'm gonna steal
their gun
in valorant the frenzy is a rifle
it's like actually insane like you can
you can destroy people with that gun
it's so
[ __ ] good dude